plus apaisant. Je vous présente
l'histoire importante avec Jean-
Sébastien.
- Le dépôt de ce projet de loi
et cette politique linguistique
marquait que l'hiver vient de
desserrer son être.
101, est adoptée par l'Assemblée
Nationale le 26 août 1977.
Elle impose l'usage exclusif du
français dans l'affichage public
et la publicité, et des
programmes de francisation pour
les entreprises de 50 employés
et plus. Elle restreint aussi
l'accès à l'école anglophone
aux seuls enfants dont un des
parents a été éduqué en anglais
au Québec, et fait du français
la langue officielle des lois
et du système de justice.
- Il est évident que la vitalité
culturelle et linguistique doit
constituer une priorité absolue.
Une priorité dont l'élément
central, qui sera à la fois
l'âme et le ciment c'est
toujours la langue.
- Les avancées sont rapides :
le français prend plus de place
dans les commerces, les
services, et les directions
d'entreprise et le pourcentage
d'enfants immigrants qui vont
dans des écoles francophones
triple en neuf 9 ans seulement.
Mais la tension est grande avec
les anglophones, qui quittent le
Québec par milliers pendant
le premier mandat
du Parti québécois.
- Quelqu'un qui ne peut plus
nous sentir comme Québécois
et qui veut partir, qu'il s'en
aille!
(protestations)
Oui, oui, oui!
- Les contestations juridiques
s'enchaînent et avec les années,
la loi 101 perd du mordant.
Québec doit sans cesse s'ajuster
aux jugements des tribunaux.
- La Charte québécoise
ne fait pas partie de la
Constitution des Canadiens.
- En 1979, la Cour suprême
déclare inconstitutionnelle
l'exclusivité du français comme
langue législative et juridique.
Puis, quelques années plus tard,
c'est au tour de l'accès
restreint aux écoles anglophones
d'être invalidé. Québec fait un
compromis et permet cet accès
à tous ceux dont l'un des
parents a étudié en anglais
où que ce soit au Canada.
Au nom de la liberté
d'expression, c'est ensuite
au tour de l'usage unique
du français dans l'affichage
d'être déclaré inconstitutionnel
en 1988. Le sujet est sensible;
des milliers de Québécois
manifestent pour protéger
leur Loi 101.
Robert Bourassa finira
par proposer un autre compromis:
l'affichage bilingue possible,
mais avec la prédominance
du français.
- ♪ C'est une langue belle
avec des mots superbes ♪
- En 2002, c'est le 25e
anniversaire de la Loi 101;
globalement, le bilan est bon,
mais une nouvelle inquiétude
apparaît : le français
au travail décline, surtout à
Montréal.
- Ce projet de loi est
suffisamment fort pour changer
la trajectoire.
- De retour au pouvoir en 2012,
le Parti québécois
propose d'imposer de nouvelles
règles aux PME de revoir le
statut bilingue des
municipalités et les conditions
d'admission aux cégeps
anglophones.
Mais l'opposition, dont fait
partie la CAQ de François
Legault, s'y oppose.
Le gouvernement de Pauline
Marois, minoritaire, abandonne
son projet de réforme.
Huit ans plus tard, la place du
français continue de décliner
dans plusieurs milieux. Une
enquête démontre entre autres
que 63 % des entreprises
montréalaises demandent la
connaissance
de l'anglais à l'embauche.
- Ça va être le geste le plus
fort qui aura été posé depuis
le dépôt la loi 101 en 1977.
- La CAQ, à son tour, y va de
son projet de réforme au moment
où tous les partis s'entendent
sur l'importance de renforcer
la loi.
Ici Jean-Sébastien Cloutier,
Radio-Canada, M